it's christmas time and have you noticed
it there are a lot of santas
around if you walk around manhattan you
can see a ton of santa you know people
dressed up as santa claus
because that's a that's a popular gig
this time of year
i'm going to call it a gig because i'm a
hep cat and uh don't laugh at that
that's more sad than funny
and uh a lot of people dressed up as
santa and i've been looking at these
people and i've been thinking like
that's a
that's a pretty good job like how do you
get to be a santa
is there a school to be santa that's
what i and then i found out there is
there are people that teach you how to
be santa there's actually a woman
who runs santa university i'm not making
this up there's a woman who runs
santa university her name is jenny zink
so we found this woman and we decided
let's have her come to my office
and show me the ropes teach me to be a
santa
it was thrilling take a look
i'm sitting here in my office with jenny
zink
jenny you're a santa trainer is that
right that's correct yeah
you train people to become santa claus
yes i do first of all we talk about what
you're going to say and what you're not
going to say yeah but ho ho ho has been
done
do you mind if i develop a different
laugh for santa go ahead
[Laughter]
that's
that's a little oxford isn't it yeah
well just be a little more natural
naturally i laugh like this
santa dews help me out with these okay
bathe daily and use a good deodorant is
for personal hygiene
and use the term what is this what folks
well you know
how many kids today might not be with
their natural parents so if you refer to
mummy or daddy or mom or dad
that might be sad for some children i
would just say
how are your parents lesbian
or gay alive or dead
possibly in prison how are they that
covers everything
these are the santa don'ts i want to
tell you right now we're going to have a
problem
no smoking flirting or drinking now
what's wrong with
flirting i mean santa's a man of the
world but he's married mrs claus is up
at the north
pole waiting yeah but she's at the north
pole oh yeah but she's something that
was a marriage that was working don't
you think they spend more time together
that's a very good point this is a
strange never promise
anything i think it'd be funny to
promise the kids like
you're getting a macintosh computer
christmas morning
santa promises and then the kid comes
downstairs
there's a toaster there he flips out
where am i
i'm at home smoking flirting and
drinking
[Applause]
so you're going to wear the white
t-shirt or are you going to wear them is
it possible
and be honest with me is it possible
that i'm too muscular to be sad
feel this right here okay it's not hard
because it hurts oh okay
this hair oh but that's some pretty good
oh that yeah very muscular what are you
doing i didn't tell you you could touch
that first time
what are you doing that's completely
gratuitous the center of your buckle
goes into the center of the fur
that's the good appearance well it was
just this appearance thing you know
what if it was like that would that
bother you yes what if we saw a santa
like this
deal with it dude that would be not good
let's put that right there okay now what
about do we put that on
is it okay to jazz up the santa suit a
little bit this is feeling a little dull
a little too traditional
look at this epaulettes okay give some
kind of a military authority
right now just check it out maybe give
him
a couple of medals just check this out
like this shows you that santa's been
places and he's kicked some
ass this is a santa who gets things done
this is a santa on the run this is a
santa who's
packing a gun this is a santa who likes
it
gentlemen nice to see you who would like
what for
i'm not happy christmas that at all that
doesn't look good this is a santa that
enjoys
a good wine uh santa who travels
extensively
this is a santa whose first marriage
failed but
he has another companion now pretend
you're a little girl and say i want a
doll for christmas
i want a doll for christmas santa
[Applause]
hmm
this is still santa except i don't have
a castle on the north pole you know what
i have
a loft that's a really cool loft
you gotta like this let's try this out
on some real
folks over at saks avenue see the way i
used folks
good that was good
this is joe bottolato he's one of the uh
operations managers here at saks
fifth avenue joe good to see you nice to
meet you kids will ask you usually what
happens when you're
not sitting in your chair where have you
been so we tried to tell them that you
just went out to feed the reindeer okay
it's hard to keep track of all these
lies but something feels wrong
about lying so much uh i'm santa claus i
have reindeer
uh you said be very vague about
everything don't give straight answers
deceive the kids i think is one of your
rules
i have problems with depression i get
very depressed
is that a is it okay if i'm kind of
low-key or
well i think when a couple of kids sit
on your lap they'll get you excited
[Music]
okay don't be nervous right
i have problems with depression you know
you don't you talking
around how are you up here oh
wow what would you like for christmas
little boy i'd say
um some of the owls that are actually um
for the uh class of it's like a teacher
rock class of 2000 2002
2001 2002.
santa's confused what kind of toy is
that
oh a beanie baby one of the owls well i
can't promise
anything how are your folks
i haven't been drinking
you want to hear my santa laughs think
you can do better
the best i can do
oh i mean i have no interest
in you sexually
[Laughter]
how are you how are your folks your
folks doing okay
my folks as in my parents yes and her
folks have passed on so far
so you're saying if the person looks
like they're in their 50s or 60s don't
ask how their folks are doing
probably okay now you tell me that's
great that's great thank you
that's terrific do you want a hug
oh
i wish i had emotions the hell
christmas came early for santa
what's your name leslie very nice to
meet you
and you're santa i'm santa
ask her if she's like quiet
she's very very attractive young woman
yes now you see hey look i taste
something maybe santa
but i'm not dead
okay now put your legs down yeah you
have to look like no
put the other leg down we need to make
you look more my pants are falling off
is that a problem
yes it will be a problem or maybe by
golly if you're lucky
he knows you'd like a brand new bike or
an electric
guitar
[Music]
do you have heineken two heineken please
when it comes on christmas eve if you
haven't been naughty
and you still believe
we will take a break we'll be right back
with vice president al gore